since the war in Ukraine began millions
of Ukrainian refugees have come to the
EU the block is also the preferred
destination for thousands of people from
other regions leading to a surge of
migration along the so-called Balkan
route to Europe but many of these
Travelers get stuck in towns along the
Serbian border DW correspondent Fanny
facha reports from Su botica where
tensions are flaring as locals say their
Border Town is being turned into a
migrant camp
another cold night spent in a tent it's
day number seven for this family from
Iraq at the subotita migration camp in
Serbia Muhammad the father of five
children says they've been on the road
since July with the aid of people
Smugglers they made it here a week ago
we left our country for the sake of our
children and their future
there is no future for kids in Iraq
Germany just like most of the people
that are inside this count but now they
are stuck in Serbia and the camp is
completely overcrowded during the first
half of this year tens of thousands of
migrants pass through the Balkan route
three times as many as last year about
10 000 are currently in Serbia
it's clear that most of the people have
made it to the Serbian border are not
looking to seek Asylum here Hungary
seems so close just crossed that fence
and you are in the European Union
but Hungary wants to keep migrants out
prime minister Victor Orban has vowed to
fortify the fences along its border with
Serbia
spearing in new border guards with an
old message
we do not believe that anything good can
come from migration
Nike
hundreds of migrants are violently
pushed back from Hungary to subotitsa on
a daily basis according to local ngos
and subotitsa residents are increasingly
frustrated
defense benefits hungry but for us there
is no chance that the migrants can move
on
they live here this won't end well
I heard that they attacked a lot of
young girls my daughter's 10 I don't
feel safe here
Serbian officials in subotitsa don't
want to speak on camera about why their
town is again becoming a hot spot for
migrants and smuggling Networks
it's a delicate issue says Pastor
tiborbuarco he goes to places that
others avoid itself
where are you from
from Afghanistan yes
he wants to give migrants some comfort
but he too is worried
the situation now is the more people who
come the more tensions will arise here
in this area
and this has an effect on the Smugglers
too
because they have more to do and
there'll be more competition
and this in parallel will cause the
situation to become more tense for the
locals for the people here too
Muhammad and his family don't know about
the growing tension in subotitsa they
just want to cross the Serbian border
into the EU before winter arrives